wolfgang bank wolfgang rather bakery  excuse me had a very special treat for  all  furry and non-furry friends earlier  today  dogs and their humans had the chance to  take pictures with santa you see him  there and it was all for a good cause  first responders were also there with  their pups all raise funds and  assist pet owners with care or even food  for their pets  as the pandemic continues especially in  this kind of difficult time with the  pandemic a lot of people lose their job  and then  they cannot provide the care they want  used to used to be so  we're trying to do something good for  them that you know just help people to  go through this hard time and then also  bring some cheer because  this year is really a difficult year for  many many people and  i just want to be able to bring some  cure to other people  so wonderful wolfgang bakery says this  event happens  once a year